mais ça sert à quoi de se relever les
manches il faut baisser son froc
[Applaudissements]
je veux faire de toi le prochain
président de la France tu en as pas
marre de tous ces blancs politiques ils
nous ont fatigué il y a personne qui
nous représente tu vois des gars comme
nous
parce que tu fais turc mon pote
animateur
ni de quartier on peut dire qu'il ne
sait pas privé de renvoyer Éric André
dans les cordes il y a pas un gars que
je connais ici qui est pas prêt à se
relever les manches mais ça sert à quoi
de se relever les manches si pour
baisser son froc
on est dans la merde parce que l'autre
grand con se présente je dirais quoi que
on va avoir un président noir un jour
elle était c'est bien les rêves
déjà c'était manager au McDo c'est un
truc de fou de quoi tu parles
Stéphane lui est candidat à la
présidentielle lever la main dites-moi
ce que ça vous inspire c'est un homme
noir banlieue
j'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie même qui
joue présenté à plus de chances que
Stéphane donc il nous faut une mesure
qui bastonne qui tape l'exemple de
douanier c'est très fort je la veux mais
en fait c'est ça notre mesure pas mangez
bien pour rien
manger halal payer rien et là tu as tous
les Arabes et crois-moi il y en a
beaucoup
et regarde-le il est sur toutes les
chaînes en train de bénir la foule
[Applaudissements]
blé on va se le faire
partie pour s'affronter au second tour
de l'élection présidentielle tu seras
jamais président et on est en France ils
sont les beaux États-Unis
ça te dirait pas d'enlever ton ce que
j'ai l'impression les gens ça allait
tant un peu ici
[Musique]